Star Wars is either the greatest thing
of all time or the worst thing of all
time there's no black and white here but
you know what it's always fun trying to
figure out where a hidden cameo is I
think I have naturally found a way to
segue into this video we're gonna watch
him screen rants 10 actors who secretly
cameo as stormtroopers in Star Wars the
only one that actually comes to mind for
me when I hear this title is Daniel
Craig in the force awakens because that
was so popularized and Nigel Godrich the
well-known music producer who everybody
in their household knows the name of
that's actually a Radiohead he was the
stormtroopers oh really
in the movie it's tied up in restraints
she decides to get a little persuasive
with the guard on hand bringing back
some that good old Jedi mind tricks to
get the job done
it takes up you try
then she sued him her sexual harassment
or part of the can drink was originally
gonna be about that's not surprising but
one that rolls over the years this might
be known for playing Silent Bob boys
work helped him not the role of a
stormtrooper his cameo appearance is in
the force awakens what ready because you
won't ever spot it Smith provides a
boys-only weekly recording a line to be
used in the movie while he doesn't get
to dress up in the stormtrooper outfit
Smith does say that was Kevin Smith
always remember them you hear that while
the original Star Wars cast is often
treated like the scene in questions he's
been trying to keep cool when a group of
stormtroopers enter the room the two
stormtroopers who flagged right behind
Finn are actually both Prince's you had
their best royal soldiers dance despite
not having any actual lines in the movie
another trooper in the scene actually
[Music]
movies like Star Trek 1:8
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
No
school is a good idea live-action films
get their own operating numbers routes
junior was only referred to a tuber with
basic numbers stormtrooper number one
news rise of the old masters transition
to strong theory video duma Canaan's
lost in the
that's a different thing are you able to
get sponsored by Disney more one is
Disney plug what about the cameo
stormtroopers in the middle William Wow
fun it's fun there's a lot I did not
know about I've got two gripes with this
list though the grapes speaker
agreements is John alright well ok for
number 10 are we really gonna count
Freddie Prinze jr. only because people
on animated shows do a whole bunch of
incidental voices in addition to their
leader supporting roles all the time the
fact that he did a couple stormtrooper
roles in addition to playing his main
Jedi role doesn't seem all that
mind-blowing to me it just seems like
what would happen on an animated show
also they missed the biggest
stormtrooper cameo with Captain phasma
Gwendoline Christie first off yes
secondly yes this may burn in hell I
hope your soul came out of that one yeah
I was having the same thought I was like
well The Simpsons uses multiple voice
actors Family Guy is all voiced by Seth
MacFarlane pretty much if you look up
like any animated show you'll see 25
credited names next to pretty much
everyone it's usually the way it goes
I'm assuming your Gwendoline Christie
one was a joke yeah because she's just a
glorified cameo
yes okay and they hyped us for that
that's true
it's like the Daniel Craig one to me is
an actual role though yeah he actually
gets to interact I get how that
quantifies as a cameo but Daniel Craig
had lines had a whole scene Daisy Ridley
said that she had no idea Daniel Craig
was under the stormtrooper outfit until
like way after filming yeah my biggest
takeaway here was actually the
narrator's closing statements of a dream
come true for a lot of these guys to
play stormtroopers now a dream come true
to be in a Star Wars movie I totally get
is it really a dream come true
to want to play a stormtrooper there's a
lot of these stormtrooper roles sound
like fun little handouts to make some
cute little cameo or have a chance to
say I did something in a Star Wars movie
for actors and JJ Abrams like calling in
favors and stuff like JJ Abrams brought
Bill Hader to do the voice of bb-8 you
can't really tell at all you would yell
later you know yeah it creates this
thing where the point seems to be that
you'll tell us later to create some sort
of neat little conversation around the
movie to continue getting people to
think about these movies or whatever
because hey most of them you could never
pick out it's true
yeah and I'm surprised surprise would
not surprise but the whole the main one
that was first blowing my mind and once
I saw what the scene was at least from
this little segment here oh no wonder
they cut it cuz you had the princes and
then you had Tom Hardy and like I'm
surges like a little stormtrooper moment
why would you cut that out and then you
see the scene in play and the last Jedi
already got enough crap for it's weird
placement of humour at times humor that
doesn't fit in the movie if that was in
there we wouldn't be talking about blue
milk we wouldn't be talking about Oscar
Isaac making a yo mama joke at the
beginning we would only be talking out
of all the jokes that would be the go-to
moment he all Ryan Johnson a slap means
yeah what no it really would be for you
just watching it here that doesn't fit
at all with the stormtroopers
does not work okay I like it just as a
personal piece of silliness but yet it
does not blow you know it's just so
surprising when you hear they had those
three huge big royalty here you're like
why would you come true it's just a
little snippet and then you hear it
oh nevermind totally makes sense why hey
cut that out well that's what's fun and
fascinating about this to me is that
stormtroopers are like the one cinematic
character I can think of who in effect
in the actual films they come from are
pretty lame don't get the job done and
everybody who wants to play one and they
are like the coolest symbol to get a
costume of like that thing of Jamie
Oliver yeah dressing as the storm
trooper in his own life and then getting
the chance to come on set I do find the
mystique of the stormtrooper very
amusing
especially because yeah if you are
invited to cameo it's almost like it's
your job to let people know it happened
there why that's I agree with you on
this weird mystique about it like when I
went to galaxy's edge at Disneyland
there's a whole store that's only
stormtrooper stuff and there are people
who really are swiping their credit and
debit cards there I have a hard time
seeing the appeal of the stormtroopers
just because do I need to explain it I
really need to explain anything
everybody has their own personal fantasy
of their life I'm the one who does know
how to yeah yeah I'm the one who's gonna
get promoted cuz I'm super good at
riding this like speeder bike and
shooting stuff and that's also a good
point that you brought up to actually in
it it sound like you're making a
sarcastic crack but there are fun cameos
of the stormtroopers in the Mandalorian
especially in below the very last
episode already they had a couple who
were like actual characters more along
the lines of what Daniel Craig did in
force awakens long enough that you could
sit there and go wait I know I know that
voice yeah something like that but some
of these are fun I mean ed Sheeran it
seems like we had no idea who he played
Joe Johnson I thought was really neat to
learn about I had no idea Joe Johnson
even worked on the original Star Wars
movie let alone innovative yes and stuff
which is one of the biggest notable
things about the original Star Wars
Kevin Smith having a line like I thought
he had a cameo in rise of Skywalker for
some reason I heard something but to
know that he
actual line is pretty neat the Michael
Giacchino one because of its director of
that movie because a nostalgia factor
sentimentality towards it that I
appreciate the thing is I don't know if
it's a dream for these guys like wanna
cameo as a stormtrooper but I will say
that I think most people who were
offered would jump at the chance to do
it it just seems like a really cool fun
thing Star Wars movie is even though
we're getting a lot more now than ever a
chance to be in one franchise that all
of us have grown up on especially if
you're in film I'm sure is a very
exciting thing so hell yeah I mean if I
had a chance to be like nothing
background stormtrooper of course I
would do it that'd be awesome
oh yeah well on the flip side I guess I
do have to give credit in a certain
sense to these people were all of
certain stature they're all recognizable
so to come in and be unrecognizable just
from the fun of its yeah like a neat
thing to get to do seems just like an
innocuous benevolent treat yeah yeah
yeah that's a good point because a lot
of them don't really go on and talk
about it a lot yeah yeah half does most
of this list I would never have known
yeah
but ed Sheeran is everywhere now Canada
people really did obnoxiously hate that
cameo in Game of Thrones
yeah hey yeah yeah I guess he's just so
shiny and shubik and and pristine that
he just doesn't fit into the world the
way they captured him was like we got
edge here yeah like a mini music here
anyway this was a great list guys if you
had the chance to cameo as a
stormtrooper unpaid would you do it
comment below would you carve out all
that time from work to be on a set or
they treat you like crap is yours the
background extra player yep that's the
end of that sentence subscribe a screen
rank could subscribe to the real rejects
click that notification bye hi it's time
for
TJ trakis TJ has gotten the word that
our mutual friends Alyssa and Dan are
moving a few doors down from us
literally they're in the same complex
it's about a 30 second walk he was
telling me or just earlier today that
he's planning on taking a trip so that
way we could meet his wife and daughter
Skye in person and that I should feel
ashamed
once I see his daughter for all the
insensitive vulgar cracks I have made
towards his daughter and TJ shoutouts
let me be clear right up front where'd
you get this impression that I was
making jokes okay why can't I just be
sincere why do you think that just
because you interpret something as
vulgar crude insensitive childish that
that would mean I'm just making a joke
these are heartfelt sentiments even if
they're hard to swallow I'm making video
compilation for your daughter for when
she turns 18 TJ we're gonna bury it
outside your house until then then you
can dig it up like a time capsule my
plan was to make your shoutout somehow
linked to Star Wars is your big source
but I'm honestly offended do you know
when your baby shows up in person I'm
saying everything right to your
daughter's face she can speak a little
bit now right I hope enough to seem to
understand that you were Rangers cuz
that'll be good only a few words she
needs to comprehend mm-hmm and if you
guys haven't seen those previous shout
outs well they're complementary
sorry teaching I'll be polite